jesse will be sharing your first
amazon personal essay so what exactly
can you tell us about this upcoming
project
the main question that i get after the
memoir is
how do you like surrender
i was afraid that i wouldn't be
confident
without alcohol when really i'm so much
more confident
without it this november will mark four
years since jessica's rock bottom had
her choose a life of sobriety
in her new amazon original essay take
the lead
out today the new york times
best-selling author gives fresh insight
into her roller coaster life journey
including the media's fixation
on her weight
from being held on the pedestal as daisy
duke then being totally taken down
four years later for wearing mom jeans
i had the weight literally of the world
on me and that's heavy and that feels
heavy to button in you know in this
audio excerpt of the essay
jessica explains the moment she finally
threw the scale away
for good three weeks before i had birdie
i weighed myself i weighed more than my
husband
a six foot three former tight end in the
nfl i burst into tears
this number suddenly wanted to push
itself to the front
and say i am what matters i put it in a
trash bag
it had to go i say throw out the scale i
walk it to the trash can i have to rid
myself of
like measuring up to like
what weight i should be because i've had
so many people tell me what weight i
need to be and
i think it's really about just how you
[Music]
feel